CBD is fantastic.
Yeah.
No psychoactive effects too,
you know,
cause that's the,
that's the,
that's the freaking stigma behind is like,
oh it's marijuana,
it's weed and it,
and we were talking about marijuana before the podcast.
Like
do it,
I'm like,
I'm coming on Joe,
should I smoke?
No chips.
No,
we watch you watch you lucid here.
Don't want you to go into the hole.
The problem is like when people don't get high and then they get high in a
pressure situation like this,
you're just like,
yeah,
go into that tonally like Gi.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It's um,
I've,
I've tried,
I've smoked four times in my life.
Yeah.
How did that go?
Ah,
not good.
I mean the free,
the first time it was my 24th birthday,
24th birthday,
uh,
I smoke with,
who was it?
A couple of friends of mine at the Olympic Training Center and they didn't do
anything cause I don't even know how to,
I don't know how to hit the blind.
I don't know.
I didn't,
yeah.
So I was like,
man,
this stuff don't affect me dog.
I ain't going to do this so,
so,
so I didn't say screw that if you want to do it again.
And then the next time was the year after with Jason Miller.
I may have Miller.
Oh,
may have knows how to hit that.
We,
yeah,
we were doing,
it was doing the ultimate fighter.
We were doing that.
And um,
one thing we do at night is a lot of people expect like,
man,
when he's not on,
is that man super cool guy.
He's a dude.
I mean there's always like kind of like being around Mike Tyson.
There's always like Aj.
Yeah,
there's always that edge to where you're in the room with them,
with the fricking lion.
Like,
yeah,
he's cool as lion ever.
But you still know what to fucking,
you know,
and may hams like that.
You're in a room,
everything's cool,
but he still has his,
he can snap at any moment.
So we're sitting on the balcony at night and we'll just talk and he would just
talk about these in the weird thing about my is he always watched,
like he watched nothing but like smart shit.
Like the news,
like the Kobe or report,
like things like that,
you know,
he wouldn't watch.
I would think he'd watched like nine oh two one oh oh
or break and shows like that.
Like,
no man,
he,
you know,
he was very intelligent guy who would just sit there and talk and I,
and um,
he gave me that nickname that night too.
And freaking,
he's like,
Bro,
your first name starts with a k,
your last name is Bush,
man.
Oops,
I'm going to fricking call you kush.
I'm calling you Kush Ha fricking.
The next day on set,
everyone calls me Kush till this day people call me Kush.
The Nigerian nightmares free.
And at that time it wasn't born yet.
You know,
the name wasn't there cause that he start fighting yet.
But so I've had nicknames all through all throughout my life,
my career,
which is the whole Ben asks for in Shit that he's trying to run with the
[inaudible].
Marty from the call today,
Marty from Nebraska.
See,
this is the thing is when I started wrestling,
I started in high school.
My coaches out this big marine dude,
you know who's in shape plus cut.
Why Dude?
And he comes up to me,
I'm five foot 200 pounds soaking wet and he's like,
oh,
is that what's your,
what's your name kid?
I'd tell them buddy,
I don't even think he paid attention.
And he's like,
man,
what you tried wrestling?
I'd never heard of wrestling.
All I've heard is WWE like,
Nah man,
I try and get hit with chairs and stuff.
I tried to do that shit.
[inaudible]
AH,
okay.
Yeah.
All I will give it a shot.
And our assistant wrestling coach was the assistant football coach,
so they kind of would poke at me.
Yeah,
you can try wrestling,
come try wrestling.
I'll do the football season.
Then the next year I freaking,
I note it up and I freaking just sign up for wrestling.
I went in and um,
he looks at these regional role,
she calling names and he goes,
come on Kamaya.
Rude.
Who the fuck?
Who is this kid?
Because this kid.
And I'm like,
that's me coach.
And he's like,
that's your name.
Yeah.
He's like,
I'm not saying that because my whole full name is Kumar Idian.
Kamar Udine Kamara dean.
And he's like,
I'm not gonna say that.
Like,
c'mon come Marty and Kmart.
Mark,
I'm going to call you Marty.
And I'm just like,
yeah,
sure,
coach.
I'm fucking five foot three,
100 pounds.
I'm just scared of this guy.
And I'm like,
sure,
let me your kid,
you don't care.
You're going to have nicknames all growing up.
So why does the UFC shorten your name to c'mon not I,
that's,
that's what my parents call me.
He's Combo.
Yeah.
My parents call me tomorrow,
but the photos like my,
my name is Joseph.
My parents call me Jo Jo.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So the,
you know,
so that it's,
it's Camaro.
That's when my parents walks calling me.
That's what I call myself.
Okay.
You know,
but my full name is Joseph.
Was it,
you know,
it's Camara Dean.
So,
um,
Marty.
Yeah.
He's like,
I'm going to call you Marty.
So fucking outline now the whole team is calling me Marty.
And so
people are so fun,
man.
I love those names.
I love that coach.
Man.
He essentially change,
essentially changed my life.
It changed the course of my life.
It was such a funny thing though to do.
Yeah.
And call you Marty close starts on a totally different letter.
I know,
but it seemed to work.
They worked so well to where,
um,
this is the thing about nicknames.
If you fucking,
if you're a guy like just a regular average guy,
you suck.
Your name dies with you,
you move on on cares,
you know?
But if you're doing something incredible,
something spectacular that name lives on.
So now Marty went from just now everyone on the team call me Marty too,
where people know about the wrestling around the wrestling start.
Can,
you know,
in high school called me Marty.
Oh,
that Marty guy that did kids good.
And then now college coaches are calling like,
oh,
I want to recruit this kid.
You know,
this Kamari and kid.
And he's like,
oh Marty.
So now they,
oh no,
me as Marty.
So now I go to college and the coach is calling me Marty,
and now the college team is calling me Marty.
Now,
here's the situation where this whole Ben asks when thing is,
like I just mentioned,
if I was just a regular guy who sucked,
no one cares.
No one knows your name,
you die out.
Right?
But because I made waves,
like I was that Marty kid that wrestled at Nebraska,
that's beaten the shit out of everyone.
Division One,
two,
three,
Nai Juko doesn't matter.
Ben knows of me.
So you know,
he's trying to cling on as something to bring it back.
Like,
oh,
this is funny.
I'm trying to hide from it.
No,
I really was Marty from Nebraska,
but everyone's at [inaudible] from the BRASSICA.
I really was that guy.